something
so do we have a musical intro uh we hit
you guys you're gonna groan right away
just like just give it a second you
think you've heard it before
ah
[Music]
you really had to do that
[Music]
[Music]
okay everyone else hearing this
it's just like this how did it get
better this is great Rick Astley song
who's remix is this Nico
uh so this
knowing you some AI [ __ ] going on
there yeah that's uh that's a song where
they took 12 seconds from Rick Astley
and then had an AI just take it over at
12 seconds to continue from there
whoa yeah
um so technically you didn't just Rick
Roll technically technically none of
that is copyrightable YouTube
what about the first 12 seconds actually
but yeah you just got the first 12
seconds
um yeah so like the past week while we
were busy getting our minds blown by
stable diffusion uh open AI dropped
jukebox which is basically the same
thing for music
so yeah the machine overlords are coming
for the artist jobs and the musicians oh
yeah
no one's safe
we're talking about the speed of change
and it's like oh it is going really fast
oh yeah yeah I don't know if they're not
oh actually it's just really crazy yeah
so uh so mark
hi hi hi oh hi Mark you know the summer
the summer we had a wonderful summer
but the leaves are changing colors
and the seasons are changing and uh
sounds like it might be time for you to
graduate I'm [ __ ] out of here
I'm
gone
G stands for diploma
yeah yeah wait if you're leaving and you
don't know in real I know a little bit I
saw an Irish Temple Run that yeah yeah
it was pretty good it was nice because
that was a proof of concept of like all
the tutorials that I watched kind of
like solidified in that moment it wasn't
that I walked in a like I saw common
said that was like wow you seem pretty
smart he knows what he's doing he's like
no I I fumbled through all those Systems
Prior and so I kind of had some dull
recollection in my brain to go I know
that system oh I can do something like
that but yeah I am uh I'm ending my
internship here for uh for good
officially officially forever so like
coming in what was your goal with with
this internship because I mean from the
outside Observer it'd be weird it might
be kind of weird to be like oh you're
just you have your own thing going on
and it's going great why would you just
be an intern somewhere else
um because it's funny
well more more just because like I I had
this idea a while ago and we talked
about this on the last podcast that I
was on
um but just like it's just an
opportunity to hang out with my fellow
peers on YouTube people that are
creative and getting into that that same
Circle it's so hard to get that even if
you're not doing YouTube or something
like that it's so hard to find
like-minded people so it was uh it was a
welcome change case to be in an
environment where there are other people
that are creatively minded in different
ways I would not be as obsessed with AI
if it wasn't for mostly you actually you
and your your perverse distortions of
reality and machines taking over
everyone's job and your Greg Rakowski
you know he's pissed at you right yeah
specifically specifically yeah wait
really no I don't know I mean maybe
creative Clash chances I was wondering
if you posted something he he said uh he
made a statement he wasn't directly at
you it was Nico you can suck okay sorry
yeah exactly but he just said like that
man they should prevent living artists
from being put into these AI programs
and I'm pretty sure it's because I don't
know who you saw type in Greg Rakowski
and it'll make good stuff but you made a
very popular video they said type in
Greg rukowski and it'll make cool it's
cool stuff yeah well you know what if if
you didn't want everybody to use his
name maybe he should have made his stuff
so cool yeah
it's his art it was uh asking for it is
that what you're saying yeah look we're
going real deep on them
that you're defining the visual
sensibility of the new Modern Age art
Renaissance I'm really sorry about that
no I get it it's good art it's well done
but it is it is an interesting uh can of
worms but I'm slowly diving deep into it
myself it's super like where so you know
obviously somebody can watch something
can get inspired by it and you know
replicate it kind of to their own filter
in your mind Mark where's the Divide
between watching singing inspired by it
versus like typing Greg Rutkowski and
just taking the uh the result and
calling it a day I mean as a let's
player I just Google whatever everyone
else is playing
that game nah not always but sometimes
you know I'm not gonna lie I do uh you
know it's it's tough I'm not an artist I
am not talented in that way come on
you're definitely an artist you make you
make so many thumbnails I'm not a like
the people of thumbnails I'm not this
artist you know I don't do this nonsense
with all these and on a tablet I don't
do none of that everything I do is just
like Mouse based and like Auto selection
based but when it comes down to like
stealing art or whether it's
interpretation you know is is it is it
good is it bad I can't make that
distinction because honestly there's so
many people that just do what I do on
YouTube and I have no problem with it
it's kind of like cool it's I started
some kind of a trend
um or you know oh some people were
inspired to play this game or oh this
game got more attention at the end of
the day a lot more people know the name
Greg gracowski because of all the people
typing it in and all people do know his
work so on an individual level he's not
suffering at all from it he is actually
benefiting from it I would imagine yeah
you'd hope he'd get more attention
by default he is you know I didn't know
who he was yeah yeah it was it was
something like art is uh you can make
the huge argument of like when as soon
as an artist makes a piece of art are
they separate from their art is it
released into the world and then it just
goes forever
um like what do you do with it if
someone decides to change it or alter it
in any way I think like I'm of the mind
like once something's out there uh it's
it's there forever and you can only try
to make as much is possible like with
unison we had every intention of being
like it's done and it's dead and there's
still people that re-watch videos you
know and it doesn't have the same
meaning of course but I can't stop them
well I mean I can copyright claim all of
the videos which we do but I can't
really do they they pop up pretty
consistently or they can post it on file
sharing websites all over yeah you'll
find them if you look you could find
them pretty easily it doesn't take too
long yeah but it's like yeah what what
can you do it is the world and the
internet is is a big place of remixing
things so it's like trying to fight
against that is a
is a battle of futility you will be
Sisyphus pushing the rock up the
mountain if you do that I read a great
quote I think this morning that was the
internet is written in Inked
and I yeah I was like oh that's yeah
yeah like once it's out there it's out
there like no matter what someone is
someone saw it and they're like oh I'm
downloading that I'm screenshotting that
I'm actually grabbing it like and
there's like 50 layers of that transfer
paper too and then they'll get sent out
to opposite corners of the world yeah
it's crazy man yeah saved forever yeah I
was talking to Griffin about it he's it
was like what are what should artists do
yeah Griffins are in-house artists by
the way yeah yeah yeah extremely
talented he has a lot of like you know
opinions on this obviously because he's
the one who's like it's like he's seeing
all of his co-workers like I can make
awesome art and he's sitting there like
making awesome art and he's like [ __ ]
but like it makes you think like if I
were an artist who's just getting
started I would be looking how do I
Define my personal style yeah into
something completely different it is not
a good time to be a CG paint painterly
concept artist right yeah like the same
Styles yeah you gotta like innovate now
and this is going to push people I think
to really innovate Styles and like make
their own like it's like on a dollar
bill like how do you make a forge proof
like thing in your art that no AI can
replicate like what is your hand right
that's possible other than maybe little
hands because yeah yeah
I can't really it's just honestly yeah
it's all hand art
ery
a turkey hand I can't help but think of
that video that we did where you came up
with your uh stop it and I'm just like
I'm gonna steal your idea
that's basically that's where we're at
yeah have you guys been finding what the
stable diffusion in particular that it
really gets that like gambling bit in
your brain where it's like oh if I just
generate once more I'm gonna get that a
perfect result and it shows that like
we've kind of been talking about that of
like it's it's addicting yeah I'm
definitely like oh I could just tweak
this one little parameter and then it'll
be perfect and it's not perfect so you
hit generate again yeah still not
perfect and you just like because every
once while it pops up oh that's nice
you'll get that little hit yeah and
you're like yes it's that little hit of
like when you know you get a haircut and
you like glance at yourself in the
mirror like
you know but you're like oh I'm a knight
someone painted me
yeah let's see what it can do next I've
been having a lot more fun with novel Ai
and I was talking to you about this have
any of you tried novel Ai No No it's
it's a it's a a story AI or AI I always
try to do AI it's a story Model
um basically it's an advanced link
linguistic model that is able to take
prompts in and generate uh story after
that their most recent version and I'm
not sponsored by them in any way I just
I have felt that thing of like just
wanting to keep going uh with this
because the news model is so weirdly
good like if I write in short stupid
sentences like he woke up hit what dark
he did and I pick up a certain preset
it'll write just like that like and then
he got up ready
like that or if I write in a less stupid
way it'll match my voice and so it's the
first time where I felt like wow I'm
writing with an extension of myself like
I was saying like you were saying a suit
of armor is on you it's not like
something's writing for me but I feel
like I can guide it and I think that's
where AI in terms of how artists are
gonna deal with it in the future have to
approach it is like it is a tool an
extension of yourself until AI becomes
real Ai and it can think for itself it's
always going to have to be guided and
used in the hand of a person and it's
how they brush with that paintbrush that
really makes it matter yeah it's
something like a time to look at history
a little bit and see like what has
happened when other machines that come
out that accelerate human workflows the
point where you think it would eliminate
humans from the from the you know
picture
and obviously you know like you know
obviously there's less coal miners now
than there were before but when you look
at like the progress of certain things
generally speaking with something that's
easier to make
people want more of it you know it's
like you know when we could start making
air conditioners easier
everybody wanted air conditioning and
now there's air conditioners everywhere
you know it wasn't like well you know I
guess the HVAC industry dried up when
air conditioners got cheap it's like no
it like it increased demand increased
like you know longing for it but it also
kind of brings up this like this era
that we kind of move into where the
internet is effectively like a second
you know pseudo reality that you project
yourself into and now when you have ai
that you can filter yourself through
your voice can be different your image
can be different you can truly be
somebody else entirely on the internet
versus what you are in real life yeah I
saw I saw I think we brought it up last
podcast this comparison of like all
these AI image generation tools are kind
of like okay when Pro Tools are like
other Daws were invented for music but
then just thinking about that now
I think we kind of go in that argument
of like it's so much more approachable
for someone in their laptop to make
music like that's a that's a big thing
but also maybe that music isn't as good
like it's there's more opportunity and
it allows people like myself like I'm
not a talented painter I'm not whatever
but I can now use stable diffusion
mid-journey whatever to create these
cool concept pieces
but does that just like dilute art like
it's like when music becomes easier to
create there's more bad or mediocre
music does this just mean there's going
to be more bad mediocre art or like
derivative because it's just I don't
know it's such a weird thing right like
it's like how
yeah you can you can mark the
advancement of civilization in the
dilution of specialization right yeah so
way back when people were extremely
specialized oh actually no actually way
way back when people generalized and
then they specialized as civilization
came up and then there comes this weird
time when there's this D specialization
and it kind of pushes people into even
tighter specializations but generally
everyone could do more and more things
and so the end result is that everyone
is able to make anything they want that
appears in their head at any moment and
the defining thing is how good is that
thing in your head how good are you at
translating this image in your head into
reality and I think like it's not gonna
there's gonna be definitely a wash of
art but in the same way that when
painters went from physical paint to
digital paint there was surely quantity
wise way more but because people were
able to practice their craft a lot more
with better tools and they don't have to
buy pain they don't have to work with
the the weirdness of physical mediums
um they're able to express our
imagination there are some digital works
of art that are that if you showed like
a Renaissance painter
just be like so freaked out at the
possibility that that could even happen
you know it'd be amazing I guess it's
it's not a bad thing ultimately because
it lowers the barrier to entry for
people to do that but I guess it's like
this argument of like
lowering the barrier to entry at the
same time diluting the art if you would
like well but yeah I don't know I don't
think there's I think things dilution is
only possible if you have to look at
everything all at once yeah
um you know it's like think of YouTube
did YouTube Delight dilute like videos
like no no there's like far better
videos on the internet now than there
were before YouTube yeah you know but
they have a systems in place to help you
organize it it's very crazy it's very
wacky yeah I guess it's just like just
because there is more and there's more
noise and there's more like derivative
and maybe not as high quality stuff
doesn't mean you're gonna see all of it
like I'm sure we're probably gonna have
I mean I'm already kind of seeing it on
social media you see this wave of like
look at this AI thing I generated it's
like cool but it's not amazing and I
think we'll just like that'll come down
and then we'll start to see like uh
artists like like Griffin even he's
already starting to you know learn the
tools being able to use that and apply
it to their craft and really be like oh
wow these already talented artists now
have this like incredible tool in their
toolbox that can just help them become a
better and especially not just better
but more efficient artists like that's
the biggest thing to me is like
just the efficiency in terms of
concepting and just like asset creation
yeah like it's amazing you can just type
out what your 3D model was that you
wanted in blender versus having to sit
there and model it like what would you
pick it's like I'd pick I'd pick the
fastest easiest way yeah I suck at
modeling yeah
I think we're also wired to be like well
I grew up with hardships and barriers so
everyone else needs to have them but
like really it's like all we've ever
been working towards is you know
d-specialization it's like I want to be
able to do everything all the time and
not go pay this guy to do it for me you
know yeah it's like it's the natural
this is the natural like it's Tech
computation and Tech and arts
they're both now meetings that's the
natural progression of things is it good
I don't know but it's it's how
it was always going to happen have you
have you been writing a book with novel
AI have you actually like been getting a
product I've been writing so much stuff
I've been having help writing scripts
I've been writing uh not necessarily
books but just like getting stories out
of my head I guess it is a book until
you make it something else
um but I I found like in the the strange
Crux that I see people going towards
like you know just because everyone can
be it Earnest doesn't mean everyone will
be an artist and again I was telling you
this about what I discovered when I was
going to look up more help about novel
AI I went under the Discord and I found
that the vast majority of the people
that are using said software and
probably stable diffusion now are just
making porn they just like a lot of the
writers are just writing smut and and
it's just one of those things where it's
like hey that I guess that is where
people would gravitate towards I suppose
so really like when you get the whole
masses being able to make things it's
kind of like maybe not the best idea but
it does leave the rest of it to like the
real the artists that are really going
to push the art art as an art form not
that oh
[Laughter]
yeah
just that robot that's like what is my
purpose yeah you write SMUD well I mean
I feel like they're the only ones who
have like an actual Market though for
this yeah
seriously good for them I gotta ship 10
chapters into this Harry Potter sorry
wasn't it the same way it wasn't like
deep fake Tech like Advanced by that
industry too like probably just yeah
that was kind of the first thing it was
porn that's right they're like okay
let's turn this into a product but you
know two it's credit it's like defects
really took a hard turn out of that
realm into like actually using it for
like really cool ideas and visual
effects yeah all that stuff yeah it's
like whether it's bringing a deceased
actor back to life or you know like I
don't know ilm was just like yeah we'll
do it
yeah exactly did they smooth out the
Kinks oh I don't know
[Laughter]
yeah it's uh it's crazy man I mean I'm
just like since coming to Corridor
getting to like kind of dive more into
deep fake stuff with you that was so
cool to me and so it's so eye-opening
how simple it is to kind of learn
because the process I mean that's the
thing is stable diffusion it's like you
did this awesome Master Class the other
day and it was like oh yeah sweet we can
just all do this we have a class
achieved the rank of Master yes
all right yeah it was yeah it was so
cool like it was really
it's all so approachable now too yeah it
gets crazy yeah
it's just a matter of like spending the
time to Google how to do it learning a
little bit of python like all that sort
of stuff but it is approachable and I
think ultimately that's a good thing
like totally yeah I think so I mean all
the similar cinematographers were
freaking out when dslrs came out and
were like yeah right these freaking
amateurs they think they can you know
just make a film with depth of
fields
like I'm sure they were pissed yeah yeah
and there's a span of a couple of years
you know it's been a couple years was
like if you were shooting digital and
you had you know the Canon 5D Mark II or
whatever it's like oh you can get
something special out of it just because
you had the camera and after a while I
was like everybody has the camera like
it's weird to think like we were really
just shooting on like these crappy
wide-angle lenses that was like all of
Home Videos for like 10 10 15 years was
just the same lenses and those like Diaz
Lars pop and were like oh
yeah Boca
you even get 24 rounds per second until
like I was graduating college what the
heck yeah
Mark so you you were in a couple
different videos over the past couple
months a couple a couple people don't
know about more than half of them
they're on Corridor digital.com
they are amazing Christmas episodes but
I wanted to ask you like
okay you can't say the Crewcuts we can
talk about the crew cut season finale
but you can't say the Crooked season
finale is to answer this question but
what video did you enjoy making the most
foreign
it's hard to pick uh I wouldn't say it
was like any of the crew cut stuff even
though that was very fun
um the unreal one because I actually
learned unreal and it was a nice treat
you know after so long getting through
there
um
it really was like kind of a fun journey
I I almost don't remember them as single
videos because it was many of them were
filmed over such a weird period of time
which is so different from how I do
things if I'm doing a video it's like
I'm sitting down until the video is done
recorded and then I'm done I'm not used
to the picking up a shot here picking up
a shot here over three days maybe a week
um and so I can't really boil it down to
a video just because it was such a
pleasant experience throughout the days
that's really nice awesome well let me
let me ask you another question that
actually whenever anytime I have a
friend visiting from like another
country
I was asking and it's like they come for
the first time I asked them like what
was the thing that you expected that
totally like was your expectation and
what's the thing that you expected that
was not at all like did not at all
turned out to be your expectation I
thought that working in a pit of people
uh basically would be uh hell and and it
was
but not for the reason that I thought it
was it was hell because not because of
the people I thought it would be hard to
get anything done and in actuality like
I got more done just because like
there's people around you there's like I
can't again pull up my my AI smut
machine and just like go to town on it
um but there's there's also uh just like
having this fun environment where
everyone's joking and you know it's not
too much pressure unless there's like a
lot of videos going on then again I
wasn't I wasn't editing like punch for
punch season four like the last episode
yeah it was more than one time where
Daniel needed a shop for crew because I
know he was asking that I was like oh
roll oh God but all for the betterment
um but it was hell because I just so
happened to do this internship at the
hottest point in summer and one of the
hottest summers in L.A in a room full of
like there's 20 computers oh
hottest dudes I mean
let's do this thank you
thank you but it's just like the sheer
heat
I didn't believe it makes your head hurt
after a while I had to run out I was
drinking water I'd never drank more
water than I was at this office because
it was just like that much I had to get
to keep cool yeah um so yeah completely
it was still the worst part of it but
not for the reasons that I thought okay
and then what what was uh the most
defiant of your expectations
defiant of my expectations something
you're like ah I like I think it'll be
like this when I get there I think this
is the thing I'll be doing or you know
oh yeah it's like it's not right I
thought I'd learned VFX
that's the secret none of us know the
effects right right of course
we all pretend we know the effects I
thought I would pick up something but
it's like I get it because when I'm in
videos my best strong suit is like in
front of the camera like that's where my
skill set has been developed over 10
years of doing YouTube
um and I'm good at editing but there was
no occurrence with which I needed to
edit there's plenty of very talented
editors here uh and then with VFX is
like I learned as much as I gave myself
time to learn I was having so much fun
doing other stuff that I actually didn't
take as much time just to actually do
the thing that I came here for
um but by sheer Association I did absorb
a lot of it and I I learned a lot about
like the process of you know file man
management peer-to-peer Communication in
terms of like bouncing things back and
forth just being in between you and
Jordan just hearing these things about
nuke and asking about things they flew
over my head but I caught a few every
once in a while nice yeah yeah man it
was a it was really cool having you in
the studio and just getting to meet you
and
um like this job's new for me being in
front of the camera and to see how like
natural it seems to you and like like
every time you're on camera like God
damn he's good it honestly helped me be
more comfortable on camera like um so it
was it was really cool just kidding to
be like oh damn like Mark's just like
improving this stuff and it's like super
like I don't know it just feels good
like and so it's helped me feel more
comfortable on camera just seeing how
comfortable you are and stuff and like I
know we've talked about having this
improv class in the studio and like that
sounds awesome like it's so cool it's
something that's so new to me still like
every time there's a camera in my face
I'm like how talk English good so you do
great
and thank you for saying it it's just
like 10 years of exposure we'll do that
to you yeah every day yeah man but it's
super cool it's just it's cool to see
like
I don't know it's always interesting in
any field to see someone that's really
like
you know on top of their craft and just
like firing like at a high level and
just being like Oh yeah I can try to
like absorb some of this by osmosis and
just you know just observing I think is
so important to learning like just being
immersed in it so it's interesting that
you say that about like just being
immersed in the environment you are
picking up little things about VFX so
it's really cool man I just think yeah
it's been awesome having you in here oh
thank you very much and likewise I like
I've learned a bunch from having you
here as well like I know you were I
mentioned this you were like texted you
this but like I know you're the
quote-unquote intern but like having you
here and like learning about your
creative process and the way you
approach things the way you approach
projects
um you know just like the way you kind
of like sort out priorities of and I
feel like you're kind of similar mindset
where when you're making something
you have to find something that's like
that excites you about right it has to
have a personal truth to it whether it
just be like I like explosions I made an
explosion scene you know that's okay if
that's what you like for that moment you
know but like it's not just about making
something you like it's also about
making something that speaks to an
audience so other people can engage with
it and finding the balance between the
two things and you know that's something
that you practice you know basically
every day with your videos on your
channel and so having you kind of bring
in that perspective and seeing how how
you approach that concept versus how we
approach that concept it was really
insightful and really interesting and
just you know kind of a reminder of like
you know pause and step away from like
the you know this video comes out in two
days we gotta get that done and just
like oh the bigger picture just slow
down take a breath think about why are
you doing this what's fun about it where
do you want to be in five months or do
you want to be in five years
which you know I try to do but there's
an extra extra nice time to get like a
second reflection on that oh thank you
yeah Nick now it's your turn to say
something nice about me yeah
your dance moves now
um
so nice
um the workshop is nice
I actually I thought that was extra cool
because it's kind of and I'm not sure
how much this is covered in crew cuts
but it's kind of like a rite of passage
for every intern to clean out our Prop
Room and workshop oh yeah and well you
just raise the bar on everyone
yeah
um so I don't know what our next intern
is going to do but it better you know
knock down a few wall s yeah yeah some
kid's gonna come in just fresh out of
high school and be like wait I need to
you want me to do what now yeah a full
remodel of our kitchen please
yeah dude it's it's honestly been
awesome creating with you and just
having you like getting to like Fender
said just like as someone who's who
films every everyone I get to see how
everyone you know acts on camera and off
camera and like
it's definitely a
just a comfort in front of camera where
I don't know like it's hard to say like
Ren has all the energy but like it takes
like 20 takes to get something
you just like say one thing and one take
and it's like oh yeah that's going in
but like it's different but like you can
definitely uh I don't know man yeah it's
been good I hope you come back for more
yeah I I hope you uh I already am again
you asked me to come in for this this uh
insta360. yes okay if I can yeah of
course no I'll be back no man yeah it's
cool I feel like sometimes I look at
life like an RPG and you just unlocked a
home base right on the map so you can
come back you know yeah
create take a snack from the fridge you
know if you're thirsty and in the
neighborhood maybe I will that's very
sweet recharge your your health you guys
are too nice like it really is uh it
just like pure exposure on doing those
skills I believe anyone can get to this
point where like they're super
comfortable in front of the camera like
there's nothing it's it's my machine
learning algorithm has just been exposed
and trained a lot of repetitions
um I don't think that they're exactly
how brains work but there is some
parallels to be said there uh and and
it's also like part of the the thing
that I worry about a lot for some other
uh like like like people that come up in
the celebrity like internet celebrity
world they're they're thrust in front of
the camera when they're not ready for it
you'll see like on Tick Tock like stars
just blow up all the kind all the time
and then suddenly they're like okay go
on TV now that's daunting even for me
the idea of like going on TV even though
it's like less people would watch me on
TV than would on my own videos
it's all the the lights and the glamor
but you get someone that has never done
any of that
um and just put them on there and then
they just crumple under the pressure
because of course they do anyone would
like it it I would have if my first year
of making videos you put me like there
actually is a a local news came to
broadcast something about a charity
stream I didn't I'm just
but you know it's it's so nice to uh not
only have like people that can recognize
that it's a cool thing to do but also
just like you guys understand it because
you do you make these videos that's part
of the reason why like it's it's so fun
to be in this environment because
everyone here has the potential it's
just everyone's at various little little
places of specialization some people
like really really excel in visual
effects some people are really pushing
art and it's like so many of these
people that fill these bars of
creativity and they're they're they
overlap to this beautiful mesh of skills
this is like a really special place here
I I like it and I'm glad that I was able
to help a little bit yeah I mean it's
really great having you I mean it takes
guts to be like I'm just gonna take a
jump let me like screw up my entire
schedule and change everything I'm doing
my daily routine I'm just gonna go do
this for a little while
and you jumped in you made it happen oh
my God my schedule got messed up yeah
man I'm so behind on so many times
is there is there like something you
will take away from this like observing
Corridor how how we operate I mean it is
a different thing obviously but like do
you think you'll Implement any any of
these lessons or like I I do think like
I love the just attention to detail you
guys put to everything like the thought
process the big planning about it and I
do try to like take that to some of the
things I do now
um now that I'm like terrible at bigger
projects I've been planning them I've
done that before but it's like the you
you have to with so many people you have
to be on the same page and like trying
to bring that out to me and talking to
my editors and getting like weekly
meetings in there so like that's in the
very boring business sense
um in the other sense is like I'm
clearly off the deep end with the AI
stuff and I was never even close to
being a part of it until I got in here
like yeah now I'm now I'm literally like
looking up uh educational videos and
lectures on machine learning algorithms
and like neural networks gaussian
processes and I'm just like I don't know
and I would never be doing that
otherwise same with electric bikes and
unicycles I'm gonna break my collarbone
at some point in the future oh yeah when
are we going to get you on a one wheel
dude come on oh man we've been trying it
just didn't happen I tried as much as I
can
all right we'll make it happen yeah yeah
all right so now that you've graduated
did I did I graduate I think this is
graduate this is like the ceremony
you've gotten your grades back but we
haven't walked yet
you're probably gonna graduate I haven't
offended my thesis
what's uh what's like your next big kind
of post Corridor thing that you want to
do I gotta make a movie
um I kind of like uh I already knew I
kind of wanted to before and but I kind
of solidified it because it just is this
realization that
um because I finished my my project in
space Markiplier and I learned a lot
from that and then I I realized I was
kind of waiting for permission to do a
lot of things especially when it came to
movies like oh I gotta get a studio to
sign up and negotiate that I was like
wait
I have the money to do this
I know how to do this and then I
realized like I know how to hire a crew
I know how to get a producer onto a
project I know how to write I know how
to edit and I know the right people to
do post-production
I can make a movie yeah period yes it
sounds easy when I say it but it comes
with like that same thing it was like
it's 10 years of exposure of doing this
to get to this point but I realized like
oh [ __ ] I don't have to wait for
anybody's permission and it's like it's
cool because that is the Mantra here's
like you guys don't wait for anybody's
permission and technically speaking I do
but with gaming videos and so when it
comes to like making a movie an official
Big Boy movie
um I realized like yeah I could do it
and I could do it just as well as anyone
else yeah so yeah that's awesome it's
like just being in something for so long
it's like those barriers to entry they
just start to dissolve because you're
just like oh wait I can do this like
it's that's such a good feeling yeah
it's also really easy to constantly like
say like the reason I'm not doing that
is because I need a producer to give me
the money or I need to have somebody
write the script for me or it's like
you could just start writing the script
you could just make it for less money
you could like you know there's nothing
really stopping you outside of me just
being like well it's a really tall
mountain and I just gotta start walking
you know that is what it's all about I
mean I know people can get discouraged
especially artists nowadays could be
like why would I even start and yes it
does get more burdensome the more people
are out there making cool stuff in an
instant but that doesn't change the fact
that the difference between someone
making something and someone being like
hey look at all these Cool Tools that
are fun but I haven't made anything as
someone just decides to do it yes decide
to keep going they just decide to take
those steps and uh then everyone else
will be sitting on the sidelines being
like Oh I would but it's just not my
chance and watch them walk right by and
go off into the sunset yeah that's like
going back to stable diffusion and stuff
I think
the artists that are like so opposed to
it I think they're gonna get left behind
a little bit which sucks to say but it's
like if you're refusing to learn like
the new tool or just do that thing and
taking that step of being like okay you
know what I just got to learn this I
just got to dive into this then
unfortunately you do get left behind and
you do get become the person that's left
on the sidelines like oh I would have
done that I just didn't Google how do I
install stable diffusion you know like
it's uh the only person that can really
you know push you forwards is yourself
ultimately yeah I mean I feel like our
generation like I guess my generation
really is I kind of the Forefront of the
generations where you can't at some
point decide you're done learning I feel
like back in the day when things were a
little bit slower you can be like I've
locked in my specialty I've refined my
skill I'm not gonna worry about learning
anything else I'm just going to stay
stay in my Lane keep my skill as refined
as it can be and be the ultimate
Craftsman
and I feel like these days if you want
to be the ultimate Craftsman you have to
constantly be willing to stop using the
tool you're using and learn a new tool
whether it's moving from one 3D package
to another 3D package to another 3D
package or different editors or even
different techniques from being like I'm
drawing it by hand to I'm using AI to
enhance my workflow to literally
inventing new workflows like you have to
keep your brain flexible and it's really
easy to like stop and like there's a lot
of people now it's like I've invested so
many points in After Effects or anything
I was like I don't want to shift gears
and like I totally get that because it
does take some time
but you also can't let your brain get to
the point where it crystallizes and you
can't shift gears and if you want to
take the time to learn a program and
you're unable to it's like you're in a
really bad spot in a world where it's
not about being good at one thing it's
about being good at learning all the new
things they rapidly come out and just
staying on top of all of it you know I'm
like dreading and looking forward to the
day that I'm like oh God I gotta learn
this new program over nuke like that was
like going from Maya to blender for me
because I was just like to reached a
point where I was like
I just I gotta learn blender like it's
free it seems like it's like
I don't know blender just it's like has
this trajectory where it's like
surpassing the industry standards crazy
it gen like it's seriously exactly same
thing with like stable diffusion because
it's like here have it take it it's so
quickly iterating and just like every
week is like a new thing where you're
like oh God like and it's daunting I
definitely had like last week I was like
oh no I'm falling behind I'm learning
these AI image generation things like
it's crazy like yeah it's uh it is
daunting like we're on this curve of
just like technology and like I feel
like every release of blender that comes
out there's some new add-on that's like
oh this is crazy cool like now there's
there's a plug-in now for blender where
you can just generate tiling textures
from stable diffusion and they're like
it's crazy just in blender you're like I
want a tile of a rock and it's just like
like seamless texture perfect 8K
what
it's crazy man it's like yeah it's how
do you stay ahead while also still
getting good at what you're learning too
because it's like
it's so you just have to invest time
like that's all it is and learn to learn
yeah yeah I did hear something
interesting about that whole thing about
like our Millennial Generation
Um being one of the first to like
continue the learning process and uh
someone pointed it out really
specifically was like oh yeah it's
because the last Generations didn't have
access to constant learning like that
wasn't a thing yeah you couldn't look up
a tutorial open source was nothing at
all there wasn't any software that could
be iterated by your neighbor who happens
to be an expert in like neural networks
for some reason because they watched a
lot of YouTube videos they watched a lot
of anime yeah
but yeah it's like it it is one of those
things where the realization that even
like growing up and getting older I am
still just as rapidly curious about new
things as I was when I was a kid yeah
and and like it's good because like the
future generation is the same way gen Z
is going to be the same way that
whatever are they going back to a
cycle I think or do we just make up new
letters with hurricanes it's like they
do loop back around I think it's gen a I
think or maybe it's like Alpha
generation or something like that that's
gonna mess with some people
the next generation is screwed the betas
dude
[Laughter]
generation comes up with that Chad face
it's good times
so who do you think of that guy that's
in like you know the Chad memes he's
just been walking around being him I
love that before the games existed and
they were just like whoa
the perfect human yeah like what happens
when he walks into a room yeah
they need to have a Convention of all
the mean people they get together you
know obviously
I just have a feeling though that like
he only not you know I hate his hesitate
to say this maybe the picture of us but
I imagine he only looks good in those
pictures at that lighting at that angle
you're probably right whereas like in
normal flat lighting like this his
features are extremely exaggerated this
[ __ ] is gigantic shephones are too high
he looked he'd look weird
maybe I'm being mean maybe I'm being an
[ __ ] maybe I'm trying to be
self-defensive about it but I just feel
like he'd look a little odd in a room
but at the same time he stepped in the
Stream and like looked up so we'd all be
like oh Jesus
for some reason I think he's like way up
there he's got to be like eight feet
tall yeah we keep looking at the ceiling
when we walk
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah man not everybody liked the joke
either but you know what God dang it
then it's not a good joke if it doesn't
piss at least one person off yeah
very funny joke
so Mark yes you just got back from a
vacation a trip a work trip slash
vacation uh yeah I was in Korea uh
vacation because I got to see my family
and that was very important haven't seen
since the beginning of covid
um progressed a lot in terms of learning
Korean so I was able to actually have a
conversation with some of my family
members that's so cool that I've never
had a conversation with wow that's the
strangest thing to think about is
um like uh my aunt emo is is Aunt for on
the mother's side
um but I didn't know that's meant Aunt I
thought all of my aunts were named emo I
was like this is what you call it all of
your awesome when you have six aunts
um but yeah I went there for filming a
documentary with my mom and uh that was
a really interesting experience because
well number one because
my mom has is not good at planning uh
logical orders of getting things which
is troublesome because I did not know
enough Korean to be able to help plan
um but number two is is great because I
learned a lot about my family's history
in Korea and where I came from because
the book that my mom wrote is called
Markiplier from North Korea which is a
very strange title
um and it's the book's not even about me
it's it's just she she did she wrote it
like that to you know that way people
will click on it
before she published it
but uh my grandpa my grandfather
um he was up before the Korean War he
was up towards the north border of North
what is now North Korea um near China uh
he had he was from a wealthy family that
owned land
um and then he started to get rumors
like they started getting rumors that
the Korean war was going down
so his parents sent him and his brother
South to run basically literally to run
um because they knew something was up
because they had had contacts and they
were just like we can't all run but at
least my sons will live because if the
sun stayed they would be recruited for
the Army and then sent off to war and
die
um so they sent Sons South and my
grandpa and his brother ran literally uh
walked a thousand miles south and as
they were going this war was like just
about to break out things were
mobilizing everything was terrible and
like right as they got across the border
war broke out and just lived in complete
poverty homelessness struggling lost his
brother because he went back up to try
to find family never came back
um I think he even joined the military
and and just like he got all my grandpa
got a letter one day that was just like
your brother was killed in Gamba and he
basically was like I don't want to live
anymore all my family's gone all of them
I never and so he actually got on a
train and went uh to go to the DMZ where
he was going to kill himself
um because he just didn't want to be a
little bit more but on that train and
this is where the story is like it's
it's one of those things where it's like
you couldn't write it like this people
wouldn't believe it happened on that
train uh there was a family friend that
had also fled from the same town that he
was from that recognized him and knew
his family and knew him specifically and
the reason they knew him is because my
grandpa has a limp he had a one leg was
shorter than the other uh because he had
this is why he couldn't join his brother
to go into the military to fight and
find his families because they wouldn't
let him because he had a disability from
his leg like giving him a limp so this
guy recognized him on the bus and said
aren't you Mr Chi and he's like I I'm a
friend of your family are you okay like
can I repay you and your family for all
the kindness you got and gave him like a
job at a military base uh gave him a
place to stay try to get his feet back
on there my dad was in the army worked
with uh on that military was in that
military base met my grandfather got
introduced to my mother literally all
these chains of events and that's the
literally the only reason I'm here I was
like tracing these events of
impossibility to get to me here today
that's why it's called Markiplier for
North Korea the real reason but it's
just like these events wow
anyway the documentary for that is
coming out yeah that was a little bit
lonely a tiny snippet of it it's way
better you better watch the actual
documentary whenever it's coming out is
that gonna be on your Markiplier YouTube
channel I don't know where it's going to
be but uh my mom said that she wanted it
to be so successful she could buy a
condo in Korea so I gotta figure out how
to do that so uh ticket prices are going
to be very expensive the ticket price is
one condo
we only need one buyer one ticket yeah
now have you done a documentary before
uh I guess you could argue that like a
lot of this stuff he did on like
unisonis is like kind of reality
documentary I did an actual we did an
actual parody documentary it was only 20
minutes but it was like hunting hee who
we made it in uh we filmed it a day I
edited it in a 13-hour Sprint
um but it was like it was a full
documentary uh those who know of hunt
have watched hunting hee who could say
yeah that's just as much of a
documentary documentary they've seen uh
so yes I I have I know the general
recipe yeah okay sweet what was your
role in this doc are you hosting what
are you directing were you in hunting he
who are this
the new one but I'm just like directing
um Ethan my buddy uh he was filming
everything
um and basically just like I'm directing
it and I'll edit it and piece it all
together and then I'll eventually
sprinkle in some more stuff as needed
for narration but yeah just doing it for
my mom and because I'm a good son heck
yeah that's like major Sun points yeah I
do yeah like oh yeah let me make a
documentary about our whole family like
tell that to my mom that's like punching
the ticket to favorites
it's not good enough because it's not a
book right because because her she wrote
a book and her English is in her first
language so the book isn't like written
well and that's not an insult to my mom
that's literally a amazing that my mom
could write a book in her second
language but it's not like well
grammatically structured
um so I'd be like this is better if you
let me transform the story into a
documentary a movie so people can really
associate the visuals with it and see it
and meet family member over there and
just really know what it is like what
Korean life was like and is now and the
comparative difference so it's like and
then but my mom's just like no book and
I was like it'll be better than a book A
book I don't know so
it's just like Mom have you heard this
thing called novel AI
I think your writing style run run it
through and see uh see what you get from
I could yeah it's just like I don't want
to rewrite it it's a disservice to my
mom's efforts to rewrite it because it
changes her voice but also it's just
like it's so much work to write a book I
just don't want to do it yeah I'd rather
make a movie totally that's pretty cool
has your mom written a book before no
her first one oh yeah wow wow yeah gutsy
oh man my mom's doing the whole thing
Minds mom's like me where it's just like
you just have an idea and you run with
it
um and it's it's infuriating to see it
happen which I mean that's how I built
the workshop is like I literally me and
my buddy John had an idea it was like we
could rebuild it
[Laughter]
Jake was just like hey if you're willing
to pay for an old like deal no but that
was like the permission where you're
like Mom Dad can I sleep over at like my
friend's house but you've already
decided yeah
you're already there
yeah
his mom said it's okay if I stayed
overnight yeah exactly yeah
like they said it was okay I swear I'll
be home with my homework oh man no
that's awesome dude that was my mom with
nursing school too so she was like I
want to be a nurse I forget what the
inspiration she saw a nurse and or had a
really nice nurse when she was giving
birth to me or my brother and uh she
didn't even really speak English at that
point but she went into nursing school
being like if I memorize the book I'll
pass she didn't know English she
memorized an English nursing book whoa
everything word for word and passed it
and also learned English at the same
time wow uh from that like my mom is
incredibly smart but also much like me
incredibly not dumb that would be a bad
Sun thing to say
illogical ah okay at times bull headed
which is where I got it from I suppose
nice love you Mom
you think she listens to the podcast no
she will now
yeah she listened the whole thing just
for this part
to hear about the book that's awesome
dude it's it's crazy like
I don't know I don't know if you felt
like this but I feel very disconnected
or have felt very disconnected from like
Heritage and stuff because we're all
like you know Americans are that's what
we are like we're all just multiple
different heritages yeah so it's it must
be very cool to like go back to the
actual places where all these little
like you said happenstances that led to
you being existing on this planet yeah
like actually went down it's something
I've been meaning to do for a long time
yeah
I think everybody should that that
history is there whether you like it or
not like no matter what it is it's there
like for the longest time like I kind of
like forgot about my Korean side you
know it was just a thing that my my
family did every few years or so we go
back and see family
um and then I'd see all these people
that I couldn't talk to and I'd be like
all right I guess it wasn't it wasn't
until a few years ago that I really
really tried to tap into it because
the realization I've always said like
I'm half Korean I'm half Korean um but
at the same time realizing that like I
am Korean like that is part of me and
that's part of who I am and like my
understanding my mother instead of just
like tolerating my mom and her quirks
and realizing like a lot of them just
come from a different upbringing in an
entirely different culture uh the way
that she thinks makes so much more sense
when I realize the way that like Korean
people think like the the the habits
that they have the the kind of like care
and attention that they put in different
places in emphasis than like
traditionally America does
um it's one of the actually the closest
to America that's why they get along so
well is uh because it's like this
individualistic mentality in Korea but
it's also extremely communal mentality
it's it's it's like the Koreans are like
this juxtaposition of so many different
things that shouldn't mix and yet they
do that's why North Korea is so like
bizarre and South Korea is so like like
prospering it's this dichotomy inside
itself hopefully get some War inside
these people so it's like really
interesting does any of what you just
said make it through in the documentary
because I think it should yeah I'll
write it down now remind me I mean like
just that I mean that realization of
like you uncovering quirks in your mom
and actually having now an explanation
culturally rooted
that's an ending right there bro that's
an ending that's what I'm saying yeah
that's pretty good all right everyone
watch this remind me because I'm gonna
forget it leave a comment down below to
remind Mark well in Reddit exclamation
remind me in so many days high future
Mark when you're listening to this
podcast to double check your notes for
this part
do I gotta listen to the podcast
I'm just kidding listen you need a
highlight do you have a highlight
Channel we don't photo crude yeah what
is that happening we actually we got the
we got the channel name oh hell yeah or
recruit crude yeah like crud yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I guess I can put it on there
so wait what's this channel for is that
all the deal for this channel is for us
to have a place where we don't have
standards yeah
okay but anyone in the crew could do it
right that was the idea anybody here who
makes something I just want to post it
and like I mean obviously everyone can
like if they make something they can
just post on their own stuff if they
want to but if they're like
I'd rather tap into a little bit more of
an audience just because I I want to
like the idea is to have this YouTube
channel where you can and it's just like
go for it you know there's no there's no
scheduled plan branding Etc it's just
you can make something you throw it up
there yeah cool that's really sweet
I think it'd be super cool I'm glad
that's happening I really am I'll just
post the password publicly and call it a
day no I'm kidding a public YouTube
channel dude I love that it get deleted
so quick
you can just start blaming people's
stuff you know you can have a little
submission form yeah oh it would be like
our spaces you know on Reddit where
people could just overwrite there's only
one video that can be up there at a time
you have to delete the video that's
really funny
we definitely gotta re-watch this one
you know yeah yeah
yeah I like that idea that was oh
there's one of your contributions
there's a lasting impact for Mark I hope
so unless it's terrible and everyone
hates it then uh not me it's just good
they'll just live there you know maybe
uh maybe that's like turn maybe we can
merge that with the guillotine Channel
I thought that's what you guys would
have done no you didn't no I think
YouTube channel
yeah somebody will come back I believe
yeah yeah I like the game teen channel
oh so did I it'll come back when uh you
know when the revolution happens
it'd be like an oddly like like how many
noodles can you cut it's like oh the
beheading of that
wait is that the governor yeah the
dystopian like Revolution the machine is
gone so we'll have to we have the blade
though so I mean it's true anything can
be a guillotine if you have a guillotine
blade right it's true you just put like
a streamer on it and drop it from high
up and just
the world is your Guillotine such a
positive
note yeah
yeah
well I look forward to [ __ ] testing on
that channel I look forward to it too
it'd be a good time that's where we can
put the quarter crew reacts with the
Cobra Kai crew reacting to COBRA Carter
reacting to COBRA Kai dude or we could
just put that on the main Channel I kind
of like we should I feel like it's main
champ yeah
I guess I'll wrap it up even though like
obviously this isn't like your last day
right here in this podcast but you know
I guess like a public video point of
view it's like it's been really cool
having you here and you taught us a lot
and I hope that
I'm sorry you didn't learn any of the
effects
um maybe next time maybe next time but
intern two yeah but we're always here to
answer your questions if you need them
and yeah it was just really cool having
your Creative Energy here and I hope
that you found value in it because we
certainly did and it was yeah it was
kind of a gift from you to have you here
oh I mean the the feeling is completely
Mutual thank you so much for allowing me
to invade the space a little bit and and
I know it like like I said from the
beginning I didn't want to like
interject any ideas you know into it but
it's just like I I get excited when I
when I see like different things and
like I get ideas like that and that's
that's how people need to you know get
ideas instead of being closed off nicely
like mine mine mine like with blender
open source stuff it thrives out in the
open so don't be afraid except for uh
there's that one person on the the
corridor digital that it will be very
happy that I'm gone so you're welcome
Mark most of all thank you for the idea
of the laxative render challenge is that
happening I think oh it's happening oh
my goodness
finally you gotta think my buddy Ethan
for that it's really his idea and I'm
stealing it so but it's open source so I
can't have it what's that happening oh
no right now yeah one hour
it's like look in your Lacroix
yeah you spring on people and you put
the computers on their lap now or into
it and you're like you had it as long as
a man who have had a lot of laxatives
throughout my life it's not that bad you
gotta poop a lot that's it it's not
painful I don't know why everyone thinks
it's like horrifically painful it's just
like oh I got a bathroom again it's the
Hat the fact that you have to go to the
bathroom 20 times yeah
or wear a diaper
that's your choice how important is that
VFX see there's so much drama in this
video so compelling speaking of render
challenges last thing the people that
made the Irish board plank asset that
you guys bought oh yeah explicitly send
us an email to be like thank you so much
for using our weird 3D video game asset
I really appreciate it
industry is like
oh my God anyways
con Peter's reaction to that he's like
no I really think we need this
yeah
filming those videos is so fun that
whole like just trial by fire format is
super good I want to continue that oh
man and just bring more people in like
don't know what I mean me each time it's
just like anybody could be in I'm so
glad you got Aaron in for the reaction
yeah dude that's so good that's amazing
I didn't know he made those that's the
thing I knew who he was I didn't know he
made those cartoons yeah same here I was
like yeah he was like oh that was you
yeah oh my God so cool yeah no the name
of Eagle Raptor was like a synonymous
with me browsing Newgrounds back in the
days like I lived for his next upload I
was like can't wait for it yeah yeah
it's crazy yeah man and then I met him
in real life what a dick
yeah no he's just he's like a
two-layered celebrity yeah yeah it's
like this like Shadow celebrity
character he used to be yeah you know
he's like I'm not that man anymore he
found a new form of success I love that
episode both uh both uh Sam and ren were
like what the heck is this episode gonna
be like what are we gonna talk about and
then like we started filming and it was
just like it didn't stop like there was
no dead space and just float and you
could tell they were super engaged and
yeah it was so thanks for helping with
that oh no no no no nothing on me it's
just an idea one last question uh do you
want that desk when you leave or like
I'm gonna get it out Friday I'm sorry
because I got okay
because I was like yeah if I get this
desk in here and computer I'll be able
to record some videos while I'm at my
internship and then I literally move it
in and a week later I'm like I Gotta Go
Korea I don't come back for a month I
Never filmed the video here not a single
video here this is the week maybe you
can do one yeah no I gotta go home
[Laughter]
the vest being displacing the bean bag
I know that we were supposed to end this
pocket like a minute ago but
Jake does not like the bean bag he
really wants to get rid of the bean bag
no and I have held on a thing I've
fought Jake for it for like six to seven
years now and it makes me proud that it
is here in the middle of the floor smack
dab in front of everybody where I can
just flop onto it at a moment's notice
it's my favorite part of the office keep
Corridor chill yeah yeah why would you
get rid of a bean bag it's big and
floppy and takes no actually yeah I had
the same realization I used to have a
bean bag in my office that I had and
then we quickly realized like this is
the biggest waste of space yeah the
couch is so much more comfortable to me
but I get it I I appreciate you sticking
by your guns yeah boom boom
that should be it all right that's it